a new search of U.S President Joe
Biden's residence has uncovered six more
classified documents Biden's lawyers
agreed to the search and the helping
Federal investigators around 30
documents have been discovered since a
first batch were found in November Mike
henna is in Washington DC with more on
what's been found at Biden's house
now at this stage all that is said is
that there were six documents which were
marked at some level of classified
classification not quite clear exactly
what level it was but also according to
President Biden's personal lawyer the
investigators also took away some
handwritten Diaries some notes that
President Biden had kept now the
material relates to his time as a
senator more than 30 years as well as
some items coming from his time as vice
president now the investigators went to
the Biden home in Wilmington Delaware by
invitation it was made open to them they
spent some 13 hours there from around
about 10 o'clock in the morning until
late at night the bidens themselves were
not there they are at their beach house
over this weekend but Biden's personal
lawyer stressing that he has nothing to
hide that they are attempting to
cooperate with the investigators in
every single way and that they will
continue to do so and make open whatever
the investigators want to look into
there is an issue involved here is that
the more the Republicans criticize
President Biden for his handling of
these documents or the lack of care in
handling the documents it comes into the
spotlight the difference between the way
Biden has handled it and the way that a
former president Trump has handled it in
Trump's case the justice department had
to seek a warrant to search his premises
Donald Trump attempted to keep the
investigators away from documents for a
long period of time and that was the
reason why they got a search warrant
well let's get more on this with Bruce
fine he's a former U.S associate Deputy
attorney general he joins us from
Washington D.C thank you very much for
being on Al Jazeera first of all how
extraordinary is it to have a sitting
president's private home searched by
federal agents
well it's quite unprecedented until uh I
don't believe that there's any precedent
for this particular kind of
Investigation
including President Nixon during
Watergate uh and President Nixon of
course had served as vice president for
eight years that's how he had access to
classified information during those
years
uh so this is quite extraordinary
uh I'd like to make this observation
that despite the fact that it's true
that the lawyers for Biden have
cooperated I think if he really is going
to uh separate himself out from Mr Trump
who's tried to block the investigation
there are things that must be done that
are more dramatic uh number one he needs
if he wants he has nothing to hide he
should wave the current privilege that
he has under the Justice Department's
doctrine of being immune from
prosecution or indictment as a sitting
president he needs to waive executive
privilege he needs to waive State
Secrets he needs to waive the Fifth
Amendment privilege against
self-incrimination say I have nothing to
hide and lastly he should consider this
you may recall when Gerald Ford was
suspected of maybe doing a crop bargain
with Nixon uh in order to obtain the
presidency he testified voluntarily
before the house Judiciary Committee I
was in the room at the time and he
dispelled any suspicions with that
testimony and the whole issue went away
if Mr Biden wants to end this drip drip
drip uh Agony that he's confronting now
there may be additional classified
documents uh given the fact that it
seems to have been rather negligently
taken uh from the official places in the
in the white house or his Senate Office
he needs to consider volunteering to
testify before Congress answering any
questions and then it will all go away
otherwise I fear going to be drip drip
drip like Watergate and it'll come
completely hand to keep his ability to
move forward on other issues I mean do
you think that he will actually go ahead
and and take that advice that he that he
will uh wave all of all of those rights
that you outlined before
well I think you should consider it I
know having worked in the executive
branch that there'll be resistance oh
we've never done that before there was
resistance to President Ford testifying
about his pardon as well
um but I think you know he he's
there may be more classified documents
out there uh
decades as Senator as well as vice
president uh and if he wants to put
he's got to tell those people listen I
have nothing to hide I'm not fearful of
anything so uh you know if it becomes uh
politically more embarrassing uh he may
well take that advice because it's not
novel in the history of the presidency
of President Reagan waived these
privileges in Iran Contra I served as
Counsel on the Iran Contra committee and
we saw Poindexter and Schultz
secretaries defense secretaries of of
states and National Security advisors
testify and Reagan himself testified in
one of the Iran Contra litigations so
it's not like it's never been done
before it's not common but here I think
the politics dictate that he should take
a second look at claiming any of these
privileges some of these documents um
relate to his time in the Senate which
is almost 15 years ago I mean how
extraordinary is that has this been an
issue that has plagued him all that time
and why do you think that it's only
coming to light now
well I think it shows I know a kind of a
a negligence if you will part of the
reason I believe is if you know
classification systems here in
Washington they're vastly abused I mean
probably my view is 90 or more of
documents classified are not and should
not be classified and so the users of
the documents and I had access to them
when I was in the Justice Department to
become kind of negligent there's really
very little or anything there that seems
sensitive and so they don't really pay
much attention uh to being careful about
it my suspicion is that if you look at
all the classified documents taken from
Mar-A-Lago and taken from Biden there's
nothing that would cause an ordinary
person to say oh my gosh this is
dangerous to the National Security so
this is why even though it's many many
years afterwards where you'd figure that
Mr Biden would have protocols to go
through it at a slow basis to see
whether he accidentally took anything it
was never done because no one really
thinks classified information really
means anything and it leaks every day
out to the Washington Post New York
Times Wall Street Journal whenever you
want to make a point and that's why I
think you find this kind of situation
occurring okay we're going to have to
leave it there but thank you so much for
your time and your Insight that's Bruce
Fine a former U.S associate Deputy
attorney general thank you